willkommen zur heutigen sitzung heute
geht es noch mal über diesen netten
herrn hier über david i um und in der
letzten sitzung hatten wir mal ein
teilstück schon gelesen aus seiner
schrift dem titel traktat über die
menschliche natur also der vitalen
möchte eigentlich seine untersuchung der
kausalität in einem größeren kontext
behandeln
also er hat dieses werk wie der name
schon sagt über die menschliche natur
verfasst und eigentlich geht es ihm um
andere polo gibt also dass die
kausalität thema das ist eingebunden in
einen größeren kontext in den kontext
der frage nach dem wesen des menschen
und der vision sagt eben dass wir diese
ganzen fragen die auch ökologischer
natur sind dass wir die nur beantworten
können indem wir eine
erkenntnistheoretische position zu
grunde legen die man heute eben in paris
muss nun also eine empirische theorie
und alle wichtigen fragen also die frage
was ist ein ursachen was sind wirkungen
was es identität was ist raum was ist
zeit diese ganzen großen fragen die
versucht david hume zu beantworten oder
zu klären könnte man auch genauer sagen
er versucht begriffe also begriffe wie
raum und zeit begriffen
sie haben wir zum beispiel raum zeit
oder kausalität
damit hängen natürlich zusammen ursachen
die versuchte alle zu beantworten da
kann man ja noch beliebig fortsetzen
metaphysische begriffe die versuchte zu
beantworten oder zu klären also was ist
jetzt zur raum was ist zeit was sollen
wir uns darunter vorstellen
die versuchte dadurch zu klären indem
man sie alle zurück führt auf erfahrung
erfahrung und erfahrung sind eben
vorstellungen zunächst vorstellungen und
dann unmittelbar sind es eindrücke als
wir haben ganz banal eindrücken
also das ist so jungs ansicht wir haben
zunächst die sonne sonne genießen also
wir machen zunächst haben wir eindrücke
sinneseindrücke durch unsere
verschiedenen sinnesorganen akustische
visuelle olfaktorisch alle möglichen
sinneseindrücke und jugend vertritt die
these es kann natürlich auch
problematisieren oder in frage stellen
das sinneseindrücke die aber auch
perzeption nennt seine perfektion dass
die distinct individuen vorliegen also
wir können einen visuellen eindruck als
solchen haben oder wir können einen
akustischen sinneseindruck haben
der ist abgrenzbar von einem anderen
sinnes 1 das natürlich eine these die
man auch in frage stellen kann aber
jedenfalls ist es dass die basis und von
diesen starken sinneseindrücken diesen
unmittelbaren sinneseindrücken
distanzieren wir uns dann in dem wir uns
an sie erinnern und indem wir sozusagen
schwache abbilder davon in unserem
gedächtnis abspeichern und dann wird aus
einem unmittelbaren sinnlichen
sinneseindruck in der mit der zeit durch
die reflexion eine schwache vorstellung
davon als eine repräsentation und die
repräsentation die dieses
ist eindruck die ist eben dann in
unserem geist wie gesagt und mit diesen
schwachen abbildern diese eindrücke die
wir abspeichern unserem gedächtnis mit
diesen vorstellungen können wir dann
verschiedene arten derart art
verschiedentlich operieren also wir
können dann zum beispiel sagen
die erste vorstellung ist ursache von
der zweiten vorstellung das ist die
wirkung oder wir können mittels unserer
einbildungskraft dass es auch noch ein
vermögen auf das human eingeht können
wir die vorstellung eine ganz bestimmte
ordnung bringen
mit unserer ein bildungsgrad wir können
uns zb etwas denken oder vorstellen was
in der welt gar nicht existiert zb
können wir wie gesagt wir können die
vorstellung eines einhorns bilden an
allen hauen da kombinieren wir
verschiedene sinneseindrücke oder auch
vorstellung letztendlich von einem horn
was einmal gesehen haben und es gibt es
ja auch hörner zb von einem nahe wahl
oder von solchen wal arten die solche
hörner vorne haben dieses horn
kombinieren wir mit der vorstellung
eines pferdes und setzen sie zusammen
unser bildungs kraft und dann haben wir
eben einen gegenstand hervorgebracht in
der vorstellung der so gar nicht
existiert aber dessen teile in der welt
natürlich als eindrücke sich dingfest
machen lassen genauso bringt jung das
beispiel eines goldenen berges als eines
riesen berges der aus gold ist natürlich
hat wir haben schon mal gold gesehen die
farbe gold
dann haben wir ein berg gesehen
kombinieren wir unsere einbildungskraft
goldfarben mit berg und haben dann an
goldenberg und jetzt geht es aber ganz
konkret um die frage hier in diesem text
den wir lesen wie es mit der kausalität
aussieht und da habe ich ein paar fragen
die ich wieder hier formulieren möchte
also welche bedingungen müssen gegeben
sein damit man nach jugend eine
kausalität relation annehmen kann
das haben eigentlich schon beantwortet
wissen sie ist noch was war so das waren
zwar bedingungen oder kontexte innerhalb
während sich nach jun
kausalität bemerkbar macht jedenfalls
für uns wie müssen ursache und wirkung
in eine konstellation zu befinden genau
jung spricht auch von kontinuität
also ich hab das beispiel gebracht immer
wenn ihr ein ton ertönt ein ton ein
bestimmter ton eine frequenz dann geht
das licht aus und wir haben diese
erfahrung sehr häufig gemacht ton licht
aus ton licht aus und könnte man
irgendwann die idee kommt hoppla ist
vielleicht der ton die ursache dass
ausgehend des lichtes das ist vielleicht
seltsam man könnte einen festlichen
koordination
es ist gar nicht die wirkliche ursache
sie können sich das beliebig anders noch
vorstellen dass sie immer zwei
ereignisse haben ereignisse
dann kommt der asb und endes nur häufig
genug eintritt und wenn es raum zeitlich
nahe genug ist dann gehen sie einen
schluss dann schließen sie dass es nicht
nur immer nach dem ersten eindruck ist
als jetzt sei der erste eindruck
und dann kommt sie sagen nicht bekommt
nach also das erlöschen des lichts kommt
nach dem erklingen des tones ich sagen
ich hier ist adam b sondern sie sagen
b weil das sind wir dazu veranlagt sagt
jedenfalls also wir neigen dazu wenn wir
ganz häufig die beobachtung machen erst
ab bbc dann sagen irgendwann nicht mehr
sein weil deshalb b oder b weil
und damit für etwas neues ein in unsere
rede was eigentlich so in der
wirklichkeit der sinneserfahrung nicht
existiert nach jung jedenfalls also wir
begehen einen schluss vielleicht sogar
auch einen fehlschuss
jedenfalls ist es ganz wichtig raum
zeitliche nehmen muss gegeben sein und
jungen was aktion noch mal jetzt zu der
zu dem punkt wenn wir jetzt sagen können
denn nicht auch angesichts der transit
ivi tät von kausalität hier ein ereignis
in diesem raum in 100 jahren ein
ereignis in den usa verursachen wasser
team darf diese auf diese frage dass du
da wäre ja garnicht raum zeitliche nähe
gegeben
100 jahre später und in den usa was sagt
jugend auf diesen punkt hin genau genau
also sagt dann kann man da eben diese
wie sie richtig sagen einige kausalkette
kann man dann versuchen zu
rekonstruieren die ist natürlich sehr
lange und sie hat ganz viele
kettenglieder sozusagen also wir haben
dann die kausalkette also so angelegt 50
an das andere
und so weiter und so fort und wenn wir
nur viele zwischen glieder einschieben
oder erkennen dann haben wir eben
irgendwann mal diese ganze raum
zeitliche distanz überbrückt natürlich
kann man sich fragen und ja gut aber
eine gewisse ausdehnung müssen doch
diese ursachen und wirkungen auch haben
diese glieder der kette
weil wenn sie keine ausdehnung hätten
also wenn sie unmittelbar sich nur
berühren würden dann würden wir dadurch
wie mir scheint gar keine distanz
überbrücken können es ist genauso wie
mit der zeit
die gegenwart ist die gegenwart
ausgetreten ja eigentlich nicht weil
wenn sie ausgedehnt werde dann würde sie
zerfallen in einem zukunfts anteil und
eine vergangenheits anteil
und deswegen kann man sich fragen ja wie
kann denn jetzt durch raum zeitliche
berührung von kausal
gliedern überhaupt eine kette erstellt
werden die dann mal 5000 kilometer und
100 jahre reicht ja also das jetzt so
viele halten den von der bürgerliste
eigens aus diensten soll weiter
mindestens theoretisch immer in zeiten
des dienst was mit dem unesco verbunden
ist natürlich davon unabhängiges oder
entscheiden
in diesem fall sind die gts berichtete
westen eigentlich ab weil sie mir ein
ganz anderes zugestanden würden hingegen
bei spieler in den teams bestanden dass
wir eine alte post in die pause retten
und mehrere da könnte man da habe ich
sagen deswegen auch wo ist die
abrechnung und diese umgebung sind ist
auch diese unmittelbar zeigen
das ist ein guter punkt das
verkompliziert die sache natürlich wir
sollten nicht immer nur annehmen dass
vielleicht eine kausalkette gibt und
vielleicht gibt es mehrere kadetten in
mehrere richtungen
das muss man sich auch noch überlegen
wir betrachten jetzt immer nur eine
direkte kausalkette man könnte sich
jetzt überlegen können kausalketten auch
interferieren wenn es sie gibt also
können sie überkreuzen überschneiden
sowas oder kann man das nicht wieder um
vereinfachen so darstellen dass er sagt
auch wenn es viele kausalketten gibt es
ist letztlich doch nur eine ist eine
sehr komplexe spannende feld
genau dieses ausdünnen der kausalen
kraft also das ist das problem der
transit wenn wir die kausalkette ganz
lang ansätzen in einer dauer von 100
jahren und von ich weiß wie viel
millionen kilometern meinetwegen dann
kann man sich fragen ja wie viel der
ursprünglichen ursächlichkeit steckt
jetzt da noch in diesen wirkungen die
wir jetzt da ganz am ende dieser kette
sehen oder wie viele andere faktoren
sind da vielleicht noch mit eingegangen
die gar nicht mehr irgendwie jetzt mit
der ursprünglichen ursache
zusammenhängen und das nennt man dann
diese kausale ausdünnung das ist
natürlich auch eine metapher schreibst
aufmachen ausdünnung ist eine metapher
jetzt hatten sie sich gemeldet
[Musik]
klein sein wenn dieses ganz sicher
wieder war die frage nach der app ist eh
mission grenze also können wir nur nicht
die die die länge der einzelnen glieder
erkennen oder hat sie keine länge hatte
es hat sie keine länge diese diese
kleine kette das ist also die frage beim
jung bleibt hier offen er sagt uns jetzt
nicht wie lange diese ein einzelnes
causales klietz sein muss aber er sagt
wenn man kann sich ja folgendes
vorstellen sie können sich aber die
frage überhaupt noch welche art von
natur dieses kausal glied ist es sagt ja
nur gegenstand sagt jack das ist in der
übersetzung und object kann einmal
seinen sohnes eindruck wir könnten jetzt
aber mal mit andere technologie an
anderen kandidaten führen wir könnten
zum beispiel sagen wir setzen an für
ursachen und wirkungen situationen
situationen damals situationen sind
ausgedehnt situationen sind begrifflich
raum zeitlich ausgedehnt ja das ist
gehört zum begriff der der eine
situation hätten wir eine situation
hätte neben hier eine situation und die
situation würden sich hier wenn sich
irgendwie berühren aber während selbst
ausgedehnt dann können wir sagen guten
situation muss überblickbar sein
situation damit seine situation ist muss
klare grenzen haben sie muss eine
episode sein man könnte auch sagen
episoden aber situation gefällt mir noch
besser weil situation immer so ein
kontexten schweiz nicht nur einen
zeitlichen einheit sondern auch so raum
zeitlichen zusammenhang zu einem gefüge
sowas abgeklemmt kann man sagen
situationen also kausal glieder sind
jetzt endlich situationen und wir haben
verschiedene situationen die situation
verursacht wurde ruft hervor die
situation b und die wiederum die
situation sehen
mit dem bild der situation könnte man
dann diese ausdehnung eines ursachen
clips oder eines wirkungsgrads noch
besser erklären wie ich finde
also wenn ihr ein heute mal in die
ontologie der der regatta von
ursächlichkeit wirkung eingehen die
situation hat den vorteil ist es eine
episode ist ein abgeschlossener komplex
und ein ereignis würde ich sagen ein
ereignis hat im gegensatz zu einer
situation als ein ereignis ist
vielleicht auch eine situation aber ein
ereignis hat innerlich noch eine
binnenstruktur ein ereignis kann sich zb
an bahnen oder aufbauen
ein ereignis kann verschiedene momente
umfassende das ereignis konzentrieren
also wenn jetzt da irgendwas passiert
hat dass ein prozess charakter da baut
sich irgendwas auf und irgendwann ist
der punkt gekommen ist die schwelle
gekommen und dann kommt die wirkung aber
das ereignis selbst würde nicht nur den
übergang von einer situation zur
nächsten betreffen also die ziert diesen
punkt soll das ereignis wäre
letztendlich dieser ganze durchlauf hier
und dann wäre das nächste ereignis also
ereignis hat eine ausdehnung eine
zeitliche ausdehnung und ereignis hat
auch eine struktur würde ich sage innere
struktur ein eigenes ist nicht nur
instanz eines moment so ein ereignis hat
eine eigene dramaturgie vielleicht
ja eine situation wäre vielleicht eine
menge oder eine konstellation von
tatsachen könnte man zum beispiel sagen
ich will dir auch nicht aus
gegeneinander ausspielen genau will ich
nicht in ein ereignis kann auch eine
situation sein vielleicht aber ein
ereignis hat noch mehr würde ich sagen
so diesen dynamischen aspekten ereignis
hat mir diese aktivistische ein ereignis
baut sich auf so genau so würde ich
sagen und das ist natürlich kann man
sagen das ist auch eine situation
situation dieses ereignisses aufbauen
des ereignisses wäre eine situation
jetzt nicht unbedingt zu diesen
dynamischen charakter muss wie mir
scheint so einer situation kann man
beschreibt vielleicht als eine menge von
tatsachen
na ja vielleicht also oder eher so eine
situation aber darüber kann man noch
reden ist eine menge von tatsachen also
diese tatsache dar dass das dass das und
das war in dem verhältnis zu dem und das
sind im verhältnis zu dem und diese
konstellation von tatsachen führte zum
anderen komplex von tatsachen den wir
situationen
es ist ein vorschlag dass man also
situationen als eine menge oder eine
konstellation hin geordnete menge von
tatsachen bestreiten
jung sagt darüber jetzt nichts wir
müssen uns immer überlegen was meinte
damit eigentlich prima partie meinte
eigentlich mit objects eigentlich sind
es eindrücke oder vorstellungen also
diese ganz bezahlen empirisch gegebenen
umständen eine weitere art und das ist
jetzt wird uns zu dieser frage die wir
gerade diskutiert haben welche art von
entitäten welcher art von entitäten sind
nach ursachen und wirkungen objects was
ist es
eindrücke dieses ist eindruck dieser
sind ist eindruck das ist noch offen
lassen welche unterloquitz ökologischen
und systemischen status hat nach jugend
die qualitäts redaktion also existiert
kausalität wirklich in der welt gibt es
sie glücklich oder ist sie nicht nur
eine projektion von uns also ist es nur
was mit unserem denken zusammenhängt das
muss man uns fragen oder hat eben diese
auffassung dass also hat eine ganz
starke des technologischen gesichtspunkt
unter thema kausalität betrachtet und
das ist natürlich bei aristoteles so
nicht der fall aristoteles und platon
die die sprechen so als ob es die
ursachen gibt es gibt diese ursache es
gibt diese und die sind diese und ob wir
uns ob wir sie erkennen können wie wir
sie erklären können das spielt jetzt
erstmal nicht so eine große rolle und
jugend rät das ganze um welche logik hat
die kausalität relation also sprich
welche modalität kommt ein spiel
notwendigkeit möglichkeit da wieder in
den heutigen zitaten etwas dazu sagen
und dann kann man sich fragen wie kommen
wir eigentlich dazu in diesen übergang
von a nach b
wie kommen wir dazu dienen zu behaupten
und wie kommen wir dazu diesen übergang
überhaupt zu erkennen weil wir haben ja
eigentlich der welt nur und das
vielleicht in einer raumzeit ich nähe
also ereignisse eigenes bier oder
gegenstand ag bestand die situation an
situation b sinneseindruck asiens
antwort b
aber wie kommen wir dazu sagen weber
deswegen der fall weil es wie kommen wir
dazu dieses zwischen a und b
das was wir die kausale kraft nun also
das was von a nach b ausgeht wie können
wir das erkennen also nicht nur die die
ereignisse sondern die logik die abfolge
die notwendig abfolge dieser ereignisse
die abfolge selbst von der hamburg 1 1
wir haben nur einen eindruck von den
ereignissen aber nichts von dem was
zwischen diesen ereignissen sich
abspielt und das ist die spannende frage
die jetzt hier beantworten möchte und er
versucht das dann mit dem begriff des
glaubens auch zu bewerkstelligen aber da
kommen jetzt noch drauf
also ich lese mal vor mir hat es noch
mal ein zitat von der letzten sitzung
dass wir nochmal zur wiederholung
richten wir also unser augenmerk auf
zwei beliebige gegenstände die wir als
ursache und wirkung bezeichnen wenden
wir sie nach allen seiten um jenen
eindruck zu finden der eine vorstellung
von solch ungeheurer tragweite
hervorrufen kann
auf den ersten blick sehe ich das
denselben nicht in irgend einer
bestimmten eigenschaft dass ich den
selben nicht in irgend einer bestimmten
eigenschaft dagegen stimmte suchen darf
denn welche diese eigenschaften auch
nicht heraus greife immer finde ich ein
gegenstand der sie nicht besitzt und
doch gleichfalls gelegentlich von uns
als ursache der wirkung bezeichnet wird
in der tat gibt es ja nichts was
existiert außer uns oder in uns das
nicht entweder als ursache oder als
wirkung irgendeines anderen angesehen
werden müsste dagegen gibt es offenbar
keine eigenschaft die allem
existierenden gemein wäre und ihm das
recht mit solchen namen bezahlt zu
werden geben könnte ja also wir finden
in uns nur vorstellungen und eindrücke
und etwas was diese ungeheure tragweite
hätte dass es im tur sache etwas anderen
sei das finden wir uns eigentlich basis
von diesen unmittelbar zilles eindrücken
nicht das ist sondern die ausgangslage
jetzt sagt er hier also das ist eine
sehr sehr die vorstellung der
ursächlichkeit muss also irgendeine
beziehung zwischen den gegenständen
entnommen sein
diese beziehung nun müssen wir zu
entdecken suchen aber das ist jetzt hier
von a nach b die kausalität liegt nicht
im plan oder mg als eindrücken sind es 1
drücken oder erfahrungs gegenstücken
sondern es liegt irgendwie zwischen
diesen erfahrungen geben stehen aber
dass zwischen den erfahrungs
gegenständen liegende es selbst
eigentlich kein gegenstand der erfahrung
gegen stellte erfahrung sind nur oder b
aber das dazwischen das nehmen wir jetzt
mal zehn meinetwegen sehr erfahren wir
eigentlich nicht wir haben keinen sinn
ist eindruck von weill oder von
ursächlichkeit ich sehe da jetzt
ursächlichkeit wenn sie das mal
begründen sollten warum sie jetzt da
ursächlichkeit sehen fühlen hören ja die
nehmen sie die ursächlichkeit war dass
man im touristisch erklären müssten
ursächlichkeit was würden sie sagen sie
würden sagen das wird so genau
diese platzierungen könnten
aus dieser erfahrung heraus
sie sagen uns richtig die ursächlichkeit
ist ein schluss allerdings etwas was ich
mit hineinbringen also c kommt nicht aus
der erfahrung dass wird nicht gegeben
sondern c also von der fh uns gegeben
ist und sie wird hineingelegt von uns
sie wird postuliert oder wird behauptet
oder wird angenommen oder mit
geschlossen wie sie es sagen also c ist
das resultat eine aktivität die von uns
stammen und die nicht in der natur liegt
weil es könnte es seien willkommen auch
genau darauf dass beim 101 einmal das
eben nicht passiert und ist also eine
erwartungshaltung gewissermaßen die wir
mitbringen also das c stand by me von
uns und b wird uns gegeben
natürlich kann man sich fragen gibt es
überhaupt etwas was durch die
sinneseindrücke uns gegeben werden kann
ich habe das letzte mal hin geschrieben
diesen mythos des gegeben als im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert wurde diese
empirische anderem mit dass uns
gegenstände der erkenntnis gegeben
würden durch die erfahrung in frage
gestellt weil gegenstände ja immer schon
eine gewisse ordnung haben sie sind
substanziell verfasst und so weiter und
so fort
und ob wir wirklich substanzen so in der
sinneserfahrung präsentiert bekommen
dass wir sie einfach nur noch aufnehmen
müssen um sie zu erkennen
das ist die große frage auch die ganze
wahrnehmungspsychologie würde sagen wir
konstruieren uns unsere erfahrung
unserer erkenntnis einer gewissen weise
selbst ganz hinten
das ist eine gute frage nach jung müsste
dann letztendlich müssten naturgesetze
genauso fraglich sein
also wenn man so ein ganz konsequenten
empirismus vertritt dann kann man sich
so kann man sagen na gut wir haben jetzt
eben hunderttausend mal die erfahrung
gemacht dass wenn ich einen apfel
loslassen ball dass er auf die erde also
dass er innerhalb einer pflegt aber es
könnte ja sein dass 100.000 1 einmal der
ball nach oben fliegt wenn ich ihn
loslassen
das kann ich aus den ball selbst in
diese situation nicht entnehmen
diesen zins eindruck und das ist genau
dasselbe naturgesetz überhaupt
gesetzlichkeiten das ist etwas was nach
ihm nicht empirisch uns gegeben wird
gesetzlichkeiten sind letztendlich
annahmen das ist dann so wie es dieses c
die von uns irgendwie hineingebracht
werden die welt und tatsächlich ist es
ja so dass naturgesetze dass der
apulischen status von naturgesetzen also
ob naturgesetze unabhängig von erfahrung
geltend dass der in frage gestellt
werden kann
also es ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass
irgendwann sich ein naturgesetz
vielleicht ändert oder dass es als
falsch erkannt wird wie auch immer oder
modifiziert werden musste sind alles
empirisch sehr gut gestützte prinzipien
aber man weiß nicht wohin die physik
noch gelangt und letztendlich passiert
die physik eben auch auf empirischen
erkenntnissen und hat keine rein apriori
basis als eine basis die aus reiner
vernunft an sie ist immer abhängig von
erfahrungs gesetzen auch wenn natürlich
im zug von isaac newton da so eine ganz
starke mathematisierung stattgefunden
hat
also dass man erkannt hat wir können
bestimmte bereiche der natur die unsere
lebenswelt betreffen die jetzt also
nicht in quanten größe sich vorfinden
oder in lichtgeschwindigkeit sind aber
hinzu lebensweltlichen kontext können
mit der natur sehr stabil mathematischen
modell ihren das gelingt uns aber in
grenzbereichen glaubt eben nicht mehr
und da sieht man schon der geltend da
auch noch die naturgesetze und so also
da haben wir dann große probleme hatte
jung würde sicherlich die geltung von
naturgesetzen diese objektive geltung in
frage stellen
das ergebnis anschließend spencer
anderen in sich weil sonst wäre das
begleichen den stand das bin ich
zwei guten läufen wenn man ausschließen
könnte bisschen gut genau das ist ein
guter punkt also wenn wir von a auf b
schließen können dann wäre das ja
logisch betrag das zu und verhältnis der
implikation wahrscheinlich ne also
logisch bisschen das wäre dann eben
wirklich so als logisch schätzen
logischen szene
wenn dann und da muss irgendwie b
enthalten sein
analytische genau guter punkt also wir
können das führt natürlich dann wieder
auch zu seiner empirischen dimensionen
zurück also wir könnten sagen wir haben
wir haben wenn adam d und dann folgt
daraus
und das wäre übergang von a nach b
aber dann müssen wir eben hier dass hier
noch annehmen und die frage ist ob das
hier
ob das hier überhaupt mehr geld und hat
ne ob wir das überhaupt begründen kann
und wir haben ja eigentlich nur als wir
haben nur sinneseindrücke von a&p und
das ist logisch begriffen als
implikationen sondern zwingende kraft
also ein logisch zwingend der übergang
von dem haben eben keinen übergang als
in unserer touristischen beschreibung
würde das hier nicht gegenstand
möglicher gegenstand erfahrung sein und
diese zwingende kraft wie hier im
übergang von a nach b liegt dies
verdanken wir eben eine generalisierung
einer wahrscheinlichkeit an
eine induktion einem induktions schluss
da kommt sehr viel von uns mitten hinein
interpretation usw
aber das ist selbst nicht auf derselben
ebene angesiedelt wie a und b also dass
es spannende frage sagt also der
gegenstand ein solcher alle sitzen
sinnes eindruck
der weist in seiner gegebenheit nicht
über sich hinaus der ist selbst genug
sagt er ist wie seine substanz und da
steckt nicht nur eine information
darüber dass er jetzt da noch eine kraft
hat oder dass ein vermögen hat sein
vermögen sehe ich ja auch nicht von dem
hatte aristoteles so ganz
selbstverständlich gesprochen
da hat eine substanz eine kraft oder ein
dünnes das vermögen etwas zu
verwirklichen das gibt es nach jung
nicht mit einem vermögen kann ich nicht
empirisch sehen
ich kann vermögen nur insofern waren im
alter sich realisiert aber das so lange
es sich retten realisiert sagt jung
sollte ich davon ausgehen dass das
vermögen nicht existiert das ist einfach
die ontologische sparsamkeit und ich
sollte nur dass an dem was zwingend
notwendig ist natürlich kann man sich
jetzt fragen ist das vielleicht nicht
doch ein bisschen zu eng gedacht ist es
nicht doch irgendwie möglich dass
bestimmte gegenstände nur in bestimmten
konstellationen existieren dass man es
also zum beispiel sagt wir müssen so
eine art von relationalen theologie
annehmen dass wir sagen gegenstände
existieren nur als objekte das ist eine
simplifizierung das hat gegenstände
existieren als gegenstand immer nur im
konstellation und das selbst macht auch
ihre gegenständlichkeit irgendwie auch
einen gegenstand ist nur ein gegenstand
in einer bestimmten konstellation und
die relation ist vom gegenstand nicht
wegzudenken das könnte man ja auch sagen
zu diesem gegenstand gehört
notwendigerweise oder essentiell eine
bestimmte konstatiert haid in der er
sich befindet und wenn wir diese
konstellation ist halt nicht
berücksichtigen dann haben wir nicht
mehr denselben gegenstand
es werden so eine relationale und logie
und
die scheint jedenfalls auszuschließen
aber mir scheint dass das durchaus
möglich wird sie sagen und gegenstand
existiert nicht einfach nur so sondern
immer als gegenstand in bestimmten
kontext das gehörte seine
gegenständlichkeit und zu
das nicht lösen würde wenn wir mal
reiten ist also es muss jetzt aus dem
unglück an die nato
das hat menschen zu nehmen und die
situation und es zu weiteren bei den
weiteren spielen bekommt dadurch eine
für diese stange halten
wir müssen es eben dann schon im
nachhinein hinein geben wir müssen also
diese relationale situiert würden wir
das hier in dassow so als ein komplexes
ding und dann kann man sich natürlich
fragen auf den touristischen ebene wie
ist uns überhaupt sowas gegeben wie
können wir so was kennen so eine
relationale und theologie an muslime
stand es dann aber das ist die spannende
frage ist hier das paar und muss nicht
auf dem pc sondern hielt sich weiter
alles geht gut dass wir einen gegenstand
gegen serbien stand uns ausgehen sind
versteht und der ersten schau angeht
selbst eine zeit da denn ist dies
allerdings mit einer der wartenden an
politik gleich dazu oder wikis ihr
wissen wo wir nicht weiter aus
an der box eine unverwechselbare
persönlichkeit anders denkt und dann das
zu wissen
und jetzt muss man dazu sagen
es gilt etwas also die software ein feld
das ist notwendig weil das hält was
impliziert das löse leben geschieden
ist es ihm kurz recht das ist wenn es
drauf machen oder weil ich doch den
eindruck ab jesus her warum hier drin
sie noch kurze zeit weiter
[Musik]
dies ist absolut der meinung muss ja
auch das alter spielt im moment geht es
mir um das ist eine möglichkeit wäre
dieser stieß auch dazu haben nicht dass
es im mobile nächstes das register zum
also sie sie sagen jetzt sozusagen wir
brauchen immer so eine prämisse die mir
noch irgendwie ins spiel mitbringen
müssen es ist tatsächlich eine ganz ganz
vertrackte situation
sie sagt nicht um skeptizismus das ist
eine große interpretatorische frage ob
jung und skeptiker war ich denke spricht
einiges dafür
also immanuel kant auf denen wir den
nächsten sitzung eingehen werden er
sagte david hume hat mich aus meinem
dogmatischen schlummert erweckt und
dogmatik ist ja etwas was sehr
unkritisch ist und immanuel kant nennt
dann seine philosophie nach dem erlebnis
von david hume nachdem er seine
schriften gelesen oder jedenfalls
vermittelt bekommen hat seine
philosophie auch eine kritische filme zu
finden
also das ist die frage wie soll man da
bitte ich um lesen ich würde sagen es
ist ein 1 1 an begriffs analytik
touristischer begriff skeptiker
vielleicht ein begriffs kritiker also
erfragt wir haben es hier verschiedene
begriffe und wir verwenden diese
begriffe so selbstverständlich eine
kausalität und so ganz wichtige hier
raum zeit und so ne aber wir sollten uns
mal wirklich gedanken machen ob wir
überhaupt gerechtfertigt sind diese
begriffe so zu verwenden wie sieht wie
wir sie verwenden und jung sagt
gerechtfertig sind wir eigentlich nur
wenn wir hier eine ganz strenge
empirische erkenntnistheorie an
und da denke ich kann man ihnen greifen
da kann man einpacken kann man sagen
also diese diese erkenntnistheorie die
ist halt viel zu simpel angesetzt sie
haben jetzt natürlich auf das logische
argumente hingewiesen was in einer
gewissen weise auch unabhängig von der
erkenntnistheorie ist da müsste man sich
fragen greift dieses logische argumente
unabhängig von der erkenntnistheorie
scheint er schon so zu sein dass man
sagt wie bekomme ich in der logik so ein
übergang hin
und das ist die frage hat jung hier zwei
unabhängig voneinander gültige
argumentationslinien hier eine logische
und eine empirische mir schon passiert
auch noch gewisse prämissen eingehen
die im puristischen natur sind aber
darüber kann man diskutieren das anwesen
fragen sie noch zum schluss immer weiter
in die tiefe
diese zeit mit der wm und diese main
köln zusätzlich geben die relationen am
die nato wird in richtung 1 und steht
mit nathan können nicht beweisen sie
überhaupt existieren
das ist und in dem medium inszenierte
neben können deshalb müssen diese sex
aber nicht neben in relation zum
beispiel die augustinus argumentiert
dass man sagt ja wir würden nicht
behaupten also sie sehen es ist lassen
sich ganz viele argumente für und gegen
david hume vorbringen wir wollen das
jetzt mal gar nicht entscheiden
wichtig ist nur es ist eine sehr
schwierige frage wie wir von a nach b
kommen können also jetzt eben ursache
und wirkung und die frage überhaupt wie
man auf einer logischen ebene kausalität
modellieren kann ist kausalität logisch
verstanden und publikations verhältnis
als ist die wirkung in der ursache schon
logisch impliziert es ist die frage man
so überhaupt kausalität denken sollte
logisch und da gibt es jetzt einen
denker auf den wir ein paar sitzungen
noch kommen das ist der weg wie heißt
der schreiben immerhin der mecki sagt so
was wir ohnehin eine hinreichende
bedingung ist teil der logischen
formalisierung der qualitäts relation
aber es ist nicht das einzige was kommt
noch so was wie wie nicht hinreichend
kommt noch dazu wie notwendig und so
eine kombination aus ganz verschiedenen
modalitäten ich sage also die frage ist
wie gesagt kann man kausalität überhaupt
zu verstehen aber jung macht das so ich
glaube auch dass jung weil hier in so
einer art von implikation ausgeht
und dann kann man sich tatsächlich vor
allem liefern ist jetzt schon
eingeschlossen
ok also jetzt geht's das ist nochmal die
wiederholung also meine meinung ist
diese können ursache simultane wirkungen
hervor bringen also mit ihren wirkung
zeitlich vollkommen zusammenfallen so
müssten müssen sie es auch sie wären
nicht ursachen wenn sie das was sie
leisten können nicht wirklich leisteten
wenn es das problem der hervorbringung
etwas anderes hervor bringen
da ist ja auch noch was ist noch was
anders ist etwas zu implizieren logisch
ist was anderes als etwas
hervorzubringen natürlich auch noch
sie sehen die grenzen der logischen
mutter im modellierungs fähigkeit also
dass er hervorbringt ist vielleicht in
einer gewissen weise
oder anders gesagt wenn er hervorbringt
was auch immer jetzt hervorbringen ist
dann könnte man sagen impliziert abe in
einer gewissen weise also es ist steht
im vermögen irgendwie im begrifflichen
vermögen im konzeptuellen umkreis
es ist darin irgendetwas ist da schon
aber das ist glaube ich noch nicht
hinreichend um das hervorbringt zu
modellieren
ja also also bs irgendwie nah enthalten
okay das muss muss der fall sein dann
mit abe hervorbringen kann
aber dieses hervorbringen das ist auf
begrifflichen ebene noch viel stärker
als nur implizieren wie mir scheint da
ist noch so eine kraft drin da ist so
eine wirksamkeit drin
und die frage ist wie können wir diese
wirksamkeit wie können wir die
begrifflich fassen dass die spannende
frage nach
und da geht es jetzt eben darum und
jetzt sagte ehmig wende nun den
gegenstand nach allen seiten und die
natur dieser notwendigen verknüpfung zu
erkennen und den eindruck oder die
eindrücke zu finden aus denen die
vorstellung derselben entstanden sein
könnte richte ich mein augenmerk auf die
bekannten eigenschaften der gegenstände
so sehe ich sofort dass die beziehung
zwischen ursache und wirkung von ihnen
nicht im geringsten abhängt betrachtet
ihre beziehungen so finde ich keine
anderen als die der kontinuität und
aufeinanderfolge die ich bereits als die
übersichtlichkeit nicht erschöpfend
bezeichnet haben
also wir finden einfach keine notwendige
verknüpfung die glos in einem bestimmten
gegenstand gelegen als das müsste dann
immer noch dieses zusatz prinzip saal
davon haben wir einfach keinen sinn dass
eindruck das ist so weit hatten wir es
und jetzt stellt er sich zwei fragen
erstens aus welchem grund erklären wie
es von notwendig dass jedes ding dessen
existenz einen anfang hat auch eine
ursache habe also es geht jetzt nicht
nur um konkrete bestimmte ursachen und
wirkung sondern es geht um das
kausalität prinzip generell als es geht
darum dass alles was existiert und nicht
nur was bestimmt ist das alles was
existiert eine ursache hat und zweitens
freute sich weshalb schließen wir dass
eine bestimmte art eine bestimmte
ursachen notwendig bestimmt zur wirkung
ab das ist also nicht mehr nur das
allgemeine sondern das ist jetzt das
spezielle dass eine bestimmte ursache
eine bestimmte wirkung hat also es gibt
ja verschiedene arten von von ursachen
und wirkungen und welche art ist der
schluss von jena auf diese und der
glaube an die richtigkeit dieses
schlosses
also das ist jetzt eine piste mische
frage aber die ist jetzt schon viel
spezifischer also es gibt ja
verschiedene arten von ursachen
und dann wird wir sollten immer auch
konkret angeben können was folgt jetzt
aus war's und hier müssen wir ganz ganz
differenziert die verhältnisse klären
und jetzt kommt sagen der neue teil den
wir jetzt in der letzten sitzung nicht
gemacht haben ich lebe das mal vor in
der tat setzt jede wirkung notwendig
eine ursache für raus weil nämlich
wirkung und -ursache correlated begriffe
sind
dies beweist aber nicht dass jedem
beginn eines daseins
eine ursache vorausgehen müsse ebenso
wenig wie daraus dass jeder jemand
notwendig eine frau hat wieder raus dass
jeder immer notwendig eine frau hat
folgt dass sie den mann verheiratet sein
müsse wie kann man jetzt das diesen
dieses correlated begriffe verstehen
perspektiven haben wir sind in sachen
qualität von hinten auf den rasen gehen
deswegen unser anschauung hat er einen
wert haben aber ändern
wer eine möglichkeit ja von der
betrachtungsweise haben sie sonst noch
eine idee wie man dieses co relativ
betrachten könnte alles immer instabilen
verhältnissen also den adern gehen also
was immer als in der relation vor
feindlich in einer recht stabilen
relation hier
momentan muss genau welches land was die
ursache ist aber dass die spieler darauf
ein dass man das der fall ist wenn man
das was man als wirkung lässt man sich
wie man solche
ebenfalls rezeption und als solche muss
demonstration für mich nicht das
als wäre das ein bisschen so ein
zirkelschluss praktisch dass man das
schon voraussetzt was man eigentlich
zeigen möchte ja
ich habe jetzt ein kardiologischer
ach so also wenn den adern bäder würde
folgen wenn nicht beta nicht dass die
contra position kontrabass genau als die
die frage ist wirklich die hier haben
wir solche ausstrahlungen habe ich mache
es mal so also hier haben wir hatten
sich die tendenz gibt es von ase
ausstrahlungen die immer schon liegen
das ist eigentlich die frage und jung
neigt dazu alle ausstrahlung und alle
relationen als extern zu betrachten die
um sagt ex relationen sind nie intern
relation ist immer was was wir nicht
empirisch als eindruck haben ist etwas
hinzu kommt als ich und sagt die ganze
relation hier müssen ausgebaut werden
und es ist nur diese engere alles andere
was da in beziehungen sich setzt das
müssen wir mit einer prämisse erst
erklären können dass da irgendwelche
kräfte drin
das ideal um sozusagen das spiel das
wollen des bildes nicht enthält dass er
nichts mehr
genau das ist ein logisches er argument
was bei den billard mal kann man ja
folgendes sagen wir haben eben wenn wir
diese aussage tätigen dass der ball das
tut dann haben wir eben implizit gewisse
naturgesetze noch mit angenommen hat da
kommt also eine ganze reihe von
zusatzeinnahmen noch ein spiel also zb
hier die gravitationskraft bleibt ebenso
konstant jetzt in den nächsten sekunden
der auch natürlich die identität dieser
ball bleibt jetzt da liegen auf den
jetzt diese wieder ball zu zur oltner da
machen wir jetzt viele zusatzeinnahmen
und die frage ist ob wir wirklich diese
zusatz annahmen machen können rein auf
empirischer basis rein aufgrund der
wahrnehmung von bestimmten gegenständen
haben sich mehrere gemeldet ich glaube
erst ziehen dann ziehen
es stimmt also also nicht immer so
mithin zu verwenden
sie würden also auch sagen es ihr eine
logische sache ein logischer
angelegenheit von hier dass das kann man
sagen es gut sprach geben spar
analytische begriffs logische und können
dann begriffs logische und es gibt eben
eine andere lesart
eben stärker noch als touristen liest ja
als sie hatten das ja so ein ins spiel
gebrachte also einmal könnte man ihn so
lesen und dann ist die frage inwiefern
geht da die erkenntnistheorie mit ein
und einmal kann man ebenso lesen und
sagt was finde ich überhaupt vor meinem
bewusstsein ohne wie verbindlich
gerechtfertigt von manche bewusstseins
gegenständen zu anderen bewusstseins
gegenständen überzugehen also macht
eigentlich so eine imperialistische
motivierte begriffs analyse könnte man
sagen
zu gehen wenn man belegen konnten aus
die berichte peruanischer sondern
innerhalb irgendwann ja eigentlich
wieder sagen müssen dass es eben geht
der minister zweimal sagen dieses land
eingesetzt funktioniert über suppen oder
einfach das sind wenn sie die
möglichkeit ist danach nur mehr jeder
kunde ist einfach überschneidungen gebe
und damit die produktion
die frage ist wirklich wie welche
berechtigung wir haben von solchen
korrelation auszugehen weil korrelation
nichts ist was oder co relativität
nichts ist was in dem er schon gelegen
ist das alles nicht was immer mit b
auftritt das ist einfach nicht gelegen
und das ist mit b immer auftritt das
verdanken wir einem weiteren schluss und
diesen schluss hier den dass es noch
weitere punkte sagt jung dass wenn adam
b diesen schluss oder diese zusätzliche
prämisse die machen wir eben nicht a
priori unabhängig von erfahrung gewinnen
wir nicht apriori sind die gewinnen wird
immer nur durch erfahren die ist also
auf einer ganz anderen ebene angesiedelt
die ist nicht rein im touristisch bei
didi ist nicht rein begrifflich zu
gewinnen außer sogar sind die ist rein
induktiv durch verschiedene schlüsse auf
einem sehr schwachen fundament ist sagt
angesiedelt
es schaue ich noch mal ob wir hier noch
einen weiteren start haben
da
also jetzt kommt praktisch ein wichtiges
zitat und jetzt kommt die erinnerung ins
spiel das ist jetzt auf seite 100 folgen
dem umbruch von 211 von der 12 wir
können danach allein auf den grund der
erfahrungen die existenz eines
gegenstandes eines anderen schwer
schließen leider aufgrund der erfahrung
existenz eines gegenstandes aus der
eines anderen erschließen also a und b
diesen übergang nur aufgrund von
erfahrung diese erfahrungen und bestimmt
sich folgendermaßen er
wir erinnern uns das wiederholt die
existenz einer bestimmten art von
gegenständen erlebt haben also das packt
stark die abseits ma wir erinnern uns
zugleich das beispiel einer anderen art
von gegenständen science b stets mit
ihnen verbunden und ihnen hinsichtlich
der beziehungen der räumlichen
nachbarschaft und zeitlichen folge in
bestimmte art zugeordnet waren
so erinnern wir uns dass wir die art von
gegenständen die wir flammen gesehen und
andererseits die art von empfindung die
wir wärmen erlebt haben zugleich rufen
wir uns ihre beständige verbindungen
allen früheren fällen ins gedächtnis
zurück ohne weiteres nennen wir dann den
ersteren gegenstand ursache und den
letzten wirkung und schließen von der
existenz des einen als coach des
visuellen sinne des eindrucks der
flammen auf die des anderen dann auf dem
haptischen sind also haptischen könnte
man sagen vielleicht sind es eindruck
der werben dabei ist zu beachten dass
jedes mal wenn wir uns von dem zusammen
vorkommen bestimmter ursachen und
wirkungen erzeugt haben sowohl die
ursachen als die wirkung von uns durch
die szene wahrgenommen und in der
erinnerung aufbewahrt worden sind dass
dagegen wenn wir nachher den kausalen
schluss ziehen jedes mal nur der eine
von uns wahrgenommen wird oder in der
erinnerung auftaucht während der andere
von uns der früheren erfahrungsgemäß
hinzugefügt wird
also das ist jetzt mehr oder weniger so
das zentrale zitat es geht also was ihr
noch mal wir zusammengefasst die momente
die jetzt die kausalität relation nach
ihm aus machen das ist jetzt glaube ich
ganz wichtig kann man noch mal versuchen
zu sammeln
können sie mir das noch mal sagen was
was ist jetzt sind jetzt die sagen
bestandteile dieser kausalen erfahrung
die wir machen oder kausalen annahmen
was sind die bestandteile an regelmäßig
könnt was doch
genau raum zeitliche nähe
und sowas
was auch zu legen sich weiter als dass
man die tatsächlich in instanz in
frauenfeld
juli vor also ein eigens vom typ bahn
flugzeug oder sind daraus bei der
fertigungsleiter instanzen von a wie
könnte man das jetzt begrifflich noch
tatsächlich müssen eine spezifische
start um einen spezifischen
straßenbauarbeiter jede stadt oder
starten sollte stadtmenschen jedenfalls
nur sagen dass man es scheint so 2 level
zu agieren und dann mit mitteln aus dem
instanzen die abstraktion der aktion
seine art zugehörigkeit oder sowas oder
verbinden hatte art zugehörigkeit so was
also das ist immer auch mit der art
zusammenhänge oder polo typisiert oder
sowas typisierte suche ich wohne auch
nicht ganz sicher spielbarkeit natürlich
kann man sich jetzt fragen wie kann ich
denn überhaupt solche klassen und
kategorien bilden allein von
sinneseindrücken also das ist eine
spannende frage also ist praktisch immer
erhalten enthalten in diesen
individuellen in dieser instanz instanz
ist schon wieder interpretation instanz
würde sagen dieser sinneseindruck gehört
dazu einer kategorie inwiefern kann ich
denn überhaupt unmittelbar sinnlich
gegebene eindrücke typisieren und sagen
sie fallen unter diese art oder gattung
liegt das in diesem sinne eindruck schon
drinnen oder ist das nicht auch etwas
was ich dann wieder von außen dran
bringen sagt mir dass er zu dieser art
gehört wenn er doch wenn doch immer
total individuell ist alles ist ein
trick ist eine total individuell
binnig gerechtfertigt sie zu
klassifizieren blickt die
klassifizierbar kite in dem sich vor
kommenden ereignissen schon enthalten
die sozusagen nicht so wichtig richtig
also es ist auf jeden fall eine
lebensnotwendigkeit
die frage ist halt ob wir das
gerechtfertigter weise tun wir können
jetzt sagen sonst kann ich nicht
überleben das ist doch grund genug jung
ist so radikal dass er sagt nein das
genügt philosophisch nicht also wird am
ende dann schon so wie sie argumentieren
dann sagt dass es die gewohnheit und es
ist so eine trägheit und es geht halt
nicht anders aber er ist damit selbst
sehr unzufrieden
auch in anderen dingen zum beispiel
kleine exkurs er versucht eben auch an
anderen begriff zu klären den des ichs
der begriff also ich raumzeit qualität
ist alles so begriffe die ihr versuchen
möchte auf die art wie es jetzt mit der
kausalität getan hat zu erklären und
beim ich sagte es gibt kein sinnes
eindruck von ich es gibt immer nur
rezeptionen da ist jetzt rot blau aber
in dem rot ist nicht enthalten dass ich
das rot ziehen
es ist nur rot da ist droht dass man
müsste das so vermieden da ist rot da
ist ein ton aber nicht ich habe den ton
weil von mir ist im aha nichts enthalten
sowie immer nicht eine kraft enthalten
ist das oder die information enthalten
ist dass es immer b hervorbringt so ist
immer als möglichen sinneseindruck auch
nicht enthalten dass ich den
sinneseindrücken und von mir selbst habe
ich nach jung kein sinneseindruck schon
sagen das was mich ausmacht sind einfach
nur die sinneseindrücke und mehr nicht
sagt dass dann metaphorisch so
beschreibt das metaphorisch oder sagt
perzeption sind wieso figuren die auf
einer bühne auftreten so auf der bühne
des geistes aber vom geist selbst haben
wir keine rezeption nahm er eigentlich
gar keine kein grund dafür
von sowas wie ein
ich auszugehen sondern dass ich es
eigentlich nur ein bündel wie gesagt ein
bündel von konzeptionen und selbst ein
bündel ist es genau genommen nicht weil
bündel wäre ja noch so ein band da wäre
ja noch sein band was diese ganzen
eindrücke zusammen halten würde
und es wäre wieder so eine relation als
jung von diesem band haben wir auch
keinen sinn des eindruck wir haben
einfach nur sonne ganz willkürlich
manchmal stabiler wenn manchmal weniger
stabilere summe menge von
sinneseindrücken und nichts mehr
und das natürlich total radikal da ist
jugend dann auch sehr verzweifelt ist
intakt weil er eben dieses ich nicht
begründen kann und genau nach demselben
prinzip läuft es auch mit der
qualitätsanalyse ab
ja es auch leid
ja das ist dann so eine art so eine
lebensweisheit sonst rassistische
historische weise aber es gibt eben
diese passagen wo jung sehr verzweifelt
ist dass er das nicht erklären kann
und tatsächlich ist dieses argument ganz
ganz gegen das von descartes berichtet
von rené descartes also jungs sagt
wirklich wir brauchen keinen träger
wir brauchen keine trägersubstanz wie
eine eine res kogge tanz um erfahrungen
machen zu können
erfahrung geschieht erfahrung wird
gehabt aber werte erfahren hat wem sie
sich präsentiert ist damit nicht gesagt
ist gar nicht notwendig kann man sie
jetzt sagen
erfahrung ist immer erfahrung für
jemanden hat im begriff der erfahrung
liegt dass es jemand ist der die
erfahrung macht also impliziert dann
vielleicht doch als begriff als
sinneseindruck die tatsache oder den
sachverhalt dass der eindruck immer in
etwas sich ein drücken muss und dass wo
sich der eindruck ein drückt das bin
jetzt noch mal ich könnte man sagen also
impliziert dann nicht doch a
insofern ist im sinnes eindruck ist dass
es da etwas gibt das diesen sinnes
eindruck hat dass es dann zum beispiel
so diese theorie der phänomenologie ja
die phänomenologie sagen dann immer es
gibt immer etwas was das ist die
intention ali thätner also ein semester
eindruck ist nur ein sinneseindruck für
ein subjekt was diesen eindruck haben
kann
aber jung ist da sehr radikal sehr klein
wir haben nur basale perzeption und
diesen völlig selbstgenügsam völlig
autonom
gute frage
also könnte man auch sagen ja ist er als
wenig frage können wir sinneseindrücke
sinnes daten so beschreiben dass wir ihn
phänomenal gerecht werden ohne dass wir
von so was wie ein subjekt erfahrung
ausgehen müssen
gut man kann sein könnte schon sagen es
ist einfach so dieser zustand ist
einfach so und wenn ich mich beschreiben
möchte dann kann ich mich nur so
beschreiben sagt ich gehe ganz in diesem
sinne ist ein druck auf und dann dann
brauche ich mich da eigentlich gar nicht
es ist halt jetzt rot es ist jetzt
totales homogenes rot ist da da ist rot
genauso wird kann das dann turm
also kann und wird dann zu argumentieren
wie sich sagen dass nicht mit einem
transzendentalen transzendenz zentrales
argument kann wird sagen wir können gar
nicht solche sachen wie kausalität
denken oder vielleicht auch nur ganz
einfache dinge wie gegenständlichkeit
überhaupt denken wenn wir nicht zugleich
voraussetzen dass da ein zentrum gibt
was diese ganzen phänomen in eine
einheit bringt das ist das argument
verkannt dann könnte man sagen brauchen
doch gar kein zentrum so willkommen doch
so zu rechnen also vieles hängt daran ob
wir wirklich von sowas wie als gegeben
ausgehen können ob uns wirklich unser
setzen offen ob da etwas gegeben ist
oder ob nicht damit etwas als gegeben
wahrgenommen werden kann wir schon
voraussetzen müssen das hier zusätzliche
leistungen spiel kommen sind die diesen
gegenstand als solchen erst konstituiert
haben aber das ist dieser mythos des
gegebenen der eben häufig dann gegen
solche starke touristischen theorien wie
bei david hume vorgebracht werden
haben sie eine idee können sie mal
überlegen wie könnte ich jung
diesen relationen
aber ich kann also kann geht ja dann
soweit und sagt wer den raum und zeit
sind reine anschauungs formen die selbst
nicht gegenständliche sind denn sie sind
die reihen aber jung würde so was eben
nicht machen sie hatten sich gewählt
er versuchte es zu tun hier versucht
raum und zeit rein auf basis der
perzeption zu begründen so was wie eine
reine anschauungs form würde er nicht
akzeptieren wie wie konntest du ist das
eben notwendig ist ungewiss
auch damals jetzt leben seitdem nicht
nur daraus folgt ergeben dass die
totalität ein resultat ist unseres uns
recht es ist genau der unterschied und
dessen hat zukunft und werde dir sagen
dass die art der speise aktivierungs
niewels rechneten ist immer gut wenn ich
also die ist kastriert wird und wie sich
ein muss so wie es sein soll und nicht
kontinent und das trio nicht die
notwendigkeit nicht und weiter also 624
haben was da wirklich ist wissen wir
eingetragen aus
nur wir müssen also die qualität sehen
ist hat damals für uns
das erfordert es zu recht genau wie sich
zum beispiel
gemeint ist und dementsprechend sorgen
genau also kann der völlig richtig kann
versucht diese überlebensstrategie die
da jetzt jung so anfühlt und so ihr so
beiläufig und auch schon bisher
kontingent anführt es geht halt nicht
anders und art von pragmatismus kant
erhebt den jungen pragmatismus zum
idealismus also während jungs sagte es
geht halt nicht anders lebensweltlich
wir müssen uns liegt eine ganze unserer
natur sagt kann nein das liegt nicht in
unserer natur sonst liegt in unserer
vernunft dass wir das tor zu machen und
es ist sein logisch notwendig dass wir
qualität annehmen weil es eben apriori
ist und jung sagte es ist nur ab
austrian aber das natürlich ganz
schwierig verkannt dann zu zeigen dass
das apriori ist also dass eben diese
ganzen übergänge jetzt auch diese
logische schluss dass der irgendwie
diese prämisse dieses von a nach b
basiert weggewischt habe dass diese
prämisse nicht irgendwie nur so hin zu
gedacht wird sondern dass diese prämisse
einen einen rationalen grund hat in
unserer struktur der erkenntnis dass das
dann enthalten ist analytisch in einer
gewissen orten die nicht analytisch
synthetisch muss man sagen synthetisch
aber apriori also unabhängig von
erfahrung und das ist eine ganz ganz
schwierige leistung die kante jetzt in
der nächsten sitzung und vollziehen muss
zusammen zu sehen bekommt
[Musik]
das krankenhaus ist sehr entschlossen
ja dieses angebot kann man schon so
sagen nur ist dieses angebot jetzt eben
bei kant nicht empirisch oder
anthropologisch zu verstehen warum hat
eine anthropologie aber es ist eben
immer logisch angeboren es gehört zu
unserer vernunft natur und jung sagt
dieses kausale schließen gehört zu
unserer natur natur empirischen natur
und kann sagt causales denken causa
anschlüsse kind gehören zu unserer
rationalen natur und das ist der große
unterschied ist es irgendwie angeboren
auch wenn angeboten empirisch verstanden
wird es ist gehört zu unserer
grundausstattung würde ich mal sagen
kann sagt kausal schließen gehört zu
unserer rationalen grundausstattung und
ist nichts kontingentes oder empirisches
es gehört zu unseren ultras ratio an
struktur und jungs sagt das gehört zu
unserer empirischen natur als
evolutionär hervorgebrachte lebewesen
die sich einfach in der natur besonders
gut zurecht finden müssen und sonst
ansonsten aussterben würden jetzt mal
zugespitzt gesagt und das also
letztendlich haben sie recht ist es
irgendwas was zu unserer natur gehört
aber zu welcher natur ist gehört darin
unterscheiden sich kant und jung also
ganz radikal kann sagt ist unsere
vernunft natur und das natürlich sehr
schwierig das aufzuzeigen warum solltest
du unsere rationalität gehören warum
sollte überhaupt zum denken als solchen
gehören das kausalität wirklich
existiert in der welt dass wir ein ich
haben so was eine trans en thale einheit
der appellation wie kann das sind wieso
sollte das zu uns gehören rational das
ist die frage
und
jetzt kommt
auch erkennen dass und liegen
das ganze alles zusammenhänge zwischen
dem leben der menschen stellen und die
stille nacht oder zu kaufen
ja also das kostet nichts ist als
einschluss in den vordergrund man kann
hierfür sorgen
ja also zumindest liegt es in unserer
natur nach yuma saal schließen zu müssen
es liegt aber eben nicht unser
rationalen natur jetzt im sinne verkannt
sondern wir müssen um irgendwie zu
überleben der immer kausalität annehmen
weil es könnte ja mal sein dass wir
damit recht haben
wie oft hat die menschheit und das ist
eben dieses astrologie beispiel gedacht
da würden kausalität relation bestehen
die sich dann später nicht so
herausgestellt haben oder bloße
korrelation waren das so aber es ist
immer sinnvoll erst mal kausalität
anzunehmen und dann sich falsifizieren
zu lassen das ist ja auch das
wissenschafts prinzip wir gehen erst mal
davon aus so sei es wenn wir eine
gewisse rechtfertigung basis haben es
war als zehn mal so dann machen wir den
induktions schluss ein bisschen nach
vorne preschen ein bisschen nach vorne
und dann können uns immer noch
korrigieren lassen unternehmen erhalten
ein was anderes an so trial and error
das ist so dieses dieses glaube das
liegt auch so ein bisschen bei jugend so
enthalten
das ist einfach dieses so können wir
eben am besten überleben wenn man
einfach mal die kausalität annehmen und
dann stellen wir fest ist doch nicht so
und dann korrigieren ist wieder jetzt
sagte hier in diesem zitat untersuchen
wir jetzt nachdem wir gefunden haben
dass wir nach der entdeckung der
beständigen verbindung beliebiger gegen
stimmte stets von dem einen gegenstand
einen schluss auf den anderen ziehen die
natur dieses schlosses und des übergangs
vom eindruck der zur vorstellung
vielleicht plötzlich schließlich zeigen
dass die notwendigkeit der verknüpfung
durch den schluss nicht aber der schluss
durch die notwendigkeit der verknüpfung
bedingt ist
also es geht jetzt darum das war auch
ihr punkt um den schluss und die
notwendigkeit der verknüpfung von a und
b die junge frau sieht ansetzt die
verdammt sich jetzt einem schluss als
sie hatten app ist emissions status und
kann unter logischen status hatte
schloss und notwendigkeit verhalten sich
so dass die notwendigkeit erst durch den
schluss kommt und nicht wir durch die
notwendigkeit zum schluss getrieben
werden was ja eigentlich wir annehmen
sollten
da liegt eine notwendige verbindung vor
und deswegen können wir darauf schließen
das wäre dann diese logische
formulierung die wir angezeigt hatten
aber es ist eben nicht so sondern die
notwendigkeit ist etwas was wir
hineinprojizieren in die welt
ich schaue mir gerade ein zitat
[Applaus]
es ist es ist eigentlich und das ist
auch in diesem zitat jetzt eigentlich
ist es dann so eine wahrscheinlichkeit
notwendigkeit also wenn wir darauf
schließen dann müssen wir eben die
notwendigkeit modifizieren
wir können da nicht mehr im sinn er eine
logische notwendigkeit davon sprechen er
sagt jetzt auf seite 1 114
da die wahrscheinlichkeit erkenntnissen
nicht die beziehung der vorstellung nach
rein als solche betrachtet seien die der
gegenstände uns zum fuß sein bringt sie
muss sie einerseits auf den eindrücken
der erinnerung und der sinne und
zugleich andererseits auf unseren
vorstellungen beruhen fehlten unseren
wahrscheinlichkeit schlüssen die
einträge gänzlich so würde der schluss
vollkommen mährisch seien fehlten die
vorstellungen so wäre die tätigkeit der
geist bei erfassung ihrer beziehung
vollzieht genau genommen als sind es
waren nicht als ein denken schließen zu
bezeichnen es muss also in unserem
wahrscheinlichkeit schießen irgendetwas
wahrgenommenes oder der erinnerung
gegenwärtiges dem geist gegeben seien
und daraus müssen wir etwas das damit
verbunden ist aber nicht gegenstand der
wahrnehmung oder der erinnerung ist
erschließen also eine art von
wahrscheinlichkeit erkenntnis wir müssen
eben die kausalität modifizieren nicht
streng logisch sehen sondern eben nur
als wahrscheinlich
dann
das ist vielleicht auch noch mal
das ist nochmal gleich ein zitat das
interessant ist sollte jemand denken er
könne diese argumentation dadurch
entgehen dass er ohne eine entscheidung
über die frage ob unser causales denkt
man sich auf demonstration oder
wahrscheinlichkeit bekenntnis stützen
demonstration ist jetzt hier nach yuma
prior isches denken also demonstration
demonstratives denken ist noch jung so
was wie so logischen schluss zu machen
also amg und dann b das ist verkehrt
jungen demonstratives denken das ist
praktisch formales schließen ab rio
schießen und davon unterscheidet er eben
die wahrscheinlichkeit bekenntnis diesen
zum schluss beinhaltet also ob causales
nehmen sich auf demonstrationen oder
wahrscheinlichkeit erkenntnis stütze die
behauptung aufstelle
alle schlüsse aus ursachen und wirkungen
beruhten auf zwingender überlegung so
kann ich nur wünschen dass diese art der
überlegung aufgezeigt werde damit wir
sie unserer untersuchung unterziehen
vielleicht ließe sich sagen dass wir
nachdem wir die beständige verbindung
gewisser gegenstände von uns
erfahrungsgemäß festgestellt sei
folgende überlegung anstellen wir finden
dass ein gegenstand von dieser
bestimmten art stets einen bestimmten
anderen gegenstand hervor es ist
unmöglich dass er diese wirkung haben
könnte wenn er nicht mit der kraft der
hervorbringung derselben ausgestattet
werden die kraft schließt die wirkung
notwendigen sich also können wir mit fug
und recht von der existenz eines
gegenstandes auf die existenz des
gegenstandes der ihn gewöhnlich
begleitete schließen die ein ehemaliger
hervorbringung schließt das dasein einer
kraft in sich die kraft schließt die
neue hervorbringungen sich diese neuer
vorbringen kann also aus der kraft und
der früheren hervorbringung erschlossen
werden
ja das ist die frage also wir finden
jedenfalls nur wir finden dass ein
gegenstand von dieser bestimmten arzt
stets einen bestimmten anderen
gegenstand hervorruft jetzt ist halt die
frage hatte die kraft hat er eine kraft
der hervorbringung in sich es soll also
für einen augenblick zugestanden werden
dass in einem beliebigen falle die
hervorbringung eines gegenstandes durch
einen anderen eine kraft und sie
schließen und das an diese kraft die
wirkung gewohnt seien
nun ist aber bereits gezeigt worden dass
die kraft nicht in den wahrnehmbaren
eigenschaften der ursachen liegt und
dass uns außer diesen wahrnehmbaren
eigenschaften nichts gegeben ist und
frage ich wie kommt man dazu in jedem
neuen falle dieselbe kraft von neuem
vorhanden zu denken da doch dabei
lediglich eben jene eigenschaften
wiedergegeben sind die berufung auf
frühere erfahrungen entscheidet hier gar
nichts sie kann höchstens beweisen dass
jena selbige gegenstand dieser jemals
einen anderen hervorrief in jenem
selbigen augenblick mit der fraglichen
kraft ausgerüstet war
sie kann dagegen niemals beweisen dass
dieselbe kraft und demselben gegenstand
oder derselben vereinigung wahrnehmbare
eigenschaften konstant vorhanden und
noch viel weniger
das mit gleichen wahrnehmbaren
eigenschaften stets eine gleiche kraft
verbunden sein müssen sollte man sagen
wir hätten erfahren dass dieselbe kraft
mit demselben gegenstand verbunden
bleibe und das gleiche gegenstände mit
gleichen kräften ausgerüstet sein
so würde ich von neun fragen mit welchem
recht wie aus dieser erfahrung einen
schluss ziehen über die in der erfahrung
gegebenen fälle hinaus der andere wartet
man diese frage ebenso wie die obige so
gibt diese antwort wiederum veranlassung
zu einer neuen frage der selben art und
so in infinitum dies beweist deutlich
dass der bezeichnete erklärungsversuchen
stichhaltig ist als auch jung sagt wenn
wir hier sagen ja gut es hängt halt mit
kräften zusammen dann kann man sich
wirklich fragen ja schließt wirklich ein
ereignis der ta immer auch eine kraft
wird das ereignis in sich erstens diesen
zwei probleme erstens schließt ein
ereignis oder ein gegenstand nie eine
kraft in sich wir haben kein sinnes
eindruck von der kraft und zweitens
können wir sicherstellen dass von einem
anderen ereignis derselben art dass da
dieselbe kraftvolle das ist eine also
zwei fehlschlüsse nach junktimiert
begehen wenn wir von kräften reden die
kausal wirksam sind und das natürlich
ganz klar gegen aristoteles gerichtet
der von sowas wie ne mit einem vermögen
von hühnermist dynamisch charakter
ausgegangen ist also mit kraft aktion
kommen wir nicht weiter wir haben nun
aber bereits früher von gewissen
beziehungen notiz genommen die uns
veranlassen von einem gegenstand seinem
anderen denkend überzugehen
auch wenn kein vernunft grund besteht
der uns zu diesem übergang nötig und wir
können die allgemeine regel aufstellen
dass der geist durch die beziehungen dh
durch die assoziation getrieben wird wo
immer er ohne von uns grund in beständig
der gleichen weise einen solchen
übergang vollziehen diese regel nun
kommt hier zur geltung die vernunft kann
uns niemals von der notwendigen
verknüpfung eines gegenstandes mit einem
anderen überzeugen auch wenn sie durch
die erfahrung und die beobachtung dass
in allen früheren fällen eine konstante
verbindung zwischen ihnen bestanden hat
unterstützt wird wenn also der geist von
der vorstellung oder dem eindruck eines
gegenstandes zur vorstellung eines
anderen oder zum glauben an denselben
übergeht so kann er dazu nicht durch die
vernunft getrieben sein sohn nur durch
gewisse faktoren welche die
vorstellungen dieser gegenstände
miteinander assoziieren und für die
einbildungskraft vereinigen hätten die
vorstellungen in der einbildung nicht
mehr zusammenhang als die äußeren gegen
den verstand zu haben scheint so können
wir nie von den ursachen auf die wirkung
schließen noch an eine
nicht wahrgenommene tatsache glauben
jeder schluss als allein durch die
assoziation zwischen unseren
vorstellungen bedingungen das ist
nochmal eine wiederholung habe ich
glaube es wird ganz klar jeder mal gegen
eine auffassung dass kausalität was mit
vernunft zu tun hat kausalität ist die
annahme der kapazitäten ist nichts
rationales so etwas rein erfahrungs
mäßiges was rein empirisches und genau
gegen diese auffassung hier gegen die
vernunft dass kein vernunft grund
besteht genau gegen diese these wird
immanuel kant argumentieren in der
nächsten sitzung
er sagt es gibt gerade vernunft grund
von kausal karls kausal über großzügig
das ist natürlich fragen ob das stimmt
also das ist ganz schwierig das jugend
zu widerlegen es ist also eine riesen
eine riesen herausforderung und er sagt
eben dieser schluss dieser kausal
schluss ist allein durch die assoziation
zwischen unserem vorstellung bedingt wir
machen die erfahrung wenn dann b
denn wir machen das sehr häufig und dann
schließen wir darauf dass auch in allen
zukünftigen fällen dass alfred wirth
oder anders gesagt wir selbst haben die
disposition wir haben die neigung wenn
etwas nur häufig genug in einer
bestimmten abfolge aufgetreten ist dann
auch für alle zukünftige fälle dasselbe
anzunehmen und das ist letztendlich der
grund für die notwendige verknüpfung der
liegt einfach in unserer disposition in
unserer anlage so zu denken
indem ich aber gäbe dass hier ein
wirkliches assoziations prinzip völlig
behaupte ich zugleich dass es zusammen
fällt mit demjenigen dass die
vorstellung der ursache und wirkung
aneinander bindet das ist den gemäßigt
allen auf diese beziehung beruhenden
schlüssen ein wesentlicher faktor ist
unsere ganze kenntnis vom zusammenhang
zwischen ursache und wirkung besteht in
dem bewusstsein dass gewisse gegenstände
immer miteinander verbunden gewesen sind
und dass ich in allen früheren fällen
und sich in allen früheren fällen als
untrennbar erwiesen haben wir können in
den grund dieser verbindung nicht
eindringen wir beobachten nur die sache
selbst wir finden zugleich dass die
beständige verbindung der gegenstände
stets eine verknüpfung derselben in der
einbildungskraft bedingt wenn wir uns
den eindruck eines gegenstandes
vergegenwärtigen so machen uns ab sofort
auch eine forschung von dem gegenstand
der in gewöhnlich begleitete demzufolge
dürfen wir in folgendem die teilweise
bestimmung des werdens wesens des
verhaltens oder glaubens 10
es ist eine vorstellung die mit einem
gegenwärtigen eindruck in beziehung
steht oder damit assoziiert ist
als er bestimmt eben den glauben und das
bewahrheiten so dass es eine
antizipation ist eine erwartungshaltung
ist dass hier wieder regelmäßigkeit
eintritt das ist für jung letztendlich
die ganze sache diese kausalität
und ob man so ein assoziations prinzip
wirklich annehmen kann
in den dingen das steht das ist die
frage
wir haben jedenfalls nach junge
einbildungskraft dessen vermögen und
psychisch vermögen die tendenz
assoziations prinzipien zu bilden
die einbildungskraft hat die tendenz
wenn etwas häufiger regelmäßigkeit
aufgetreten ist das dann für alle
zukünftigen fälle zu tun aber es ist
eben uns in unserer psychischen
ausstattung begründet und nicht durch
die verluste nicht ab obgleich die
ursächlichkeit eine philosophische
beziehung ist sofern sie die kontinuität
die aufeinanderfolge und die beständige
verbindung einschließt so sind wir nach
oben gesagt doch nur soweit sie eine
natürliche beziehung ist das heißt einen
zusammenhang unserer vorstellung bedingt
imstande auf ihr denken etwas aufzubauen
oder ein schluss aus ihr zu ziehen als
wir haben jetzt muss man zusammenfassend
diese drei momente der ursächlichkeit
die sich begrifflich so analysieren
lässt noch jung wir haben die
kontinuität also die raum zeitliche nähe
wir haben die aufeinanderfolge dass also
die ursache vor der wirkung ist einer
gewissen weise und die beständige
verbindung von ursache und wirkung
und das ist nach jugend keine
vernünftige beziehung nichts was mit
unserer 1500 sondern dass es natürliche
beziehung die letztendlich mit unseren
vorstellungen zu tun haben
hier ist natürlich jetzt noch nicht
enthalten die notwendigkeit der
kausalität situation wo könnt ihr jetzt
hier in diesen drei momenten die
notwendigkeit ins spiel kommen haben sie
eine idee hatte sie so drei punkte
genannt wo ist hier die notwendigkeit
drin
nur die kraft von der man ausgehen
in der kontinuität wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr
ja genau
also hier die beständige verbindung
wobei überlegen sie mal könnten nicht
zwei ereignisse immer in beständiger
verbindung auftreten ohne dass sie
kausal bedingt sind der das möglich
bildung ist wichtig aber ist darin schon
die noten ist richtig es gibt ein
unterschied ist ganz wichtig die
aufeinanderfolge ist jetzt eben immer
singulär
und das ist in allen fällen zu immer
wenn ich die ursache habe habe ich auch
die wirkung aber es ist mit der
beständigen verbindung notwendigkeit
impliziert ja deswegen fraglich sein das
ist so dass da ist eben die
notwendigkeit nicht enthalten die
bekommen wir damit nicht so wie meine
kraft
das ist alles ziemlich wenig was vampire
gegeben haben und wir bringen dann
letztendlich selbst diese kausalität ins
spiel habe ich noch jemanden übersehen
der sich gemeldet hatte also
zusammenfassend kann man sagen
kausalität ist versuch etwas was
ereignisse oder gegenstände unserer
erfahrung betrifft
und was als solches nicht empirisch
erkannt werden kann also die notwendige
bezüglich kite zwischen zwei ereignissen
sie notwendig verbindung delikt nicht
selbst in diesen ereignissen begründet
aber in diesen erfahrungs gegenstimmen
begründet wie er selbst bringen die
notwendigkeit ins spiel in dem wir
kausale schlüsse ziehen
die sind aber empirisch bedingt und sieb
passieren letztendlich darauf dass wir
einfach in der lebenswelt zurechtkommen
müssen das ist so die die empirische
grundlage und jedenfalls hat jung hier
schon sehr viel analysiert dass er
gezeigt hat
ursache wirkung müssen raum zeitlich
sehr eng miteinander zusammen hängen und
er hat auch die sogenannte regula ruetz
theorie der kausalität formuliert das
heißt kausalität bedeutet einfach nur
regel
der abfolge paarweise abfolge von
ereignissen des typs so kann man
kausalität bestimmen also die sogenannte
regular readers theorie der kausalität
aber das ist natürlich ein bisschen zu
wenig weil man eben doch mit kausalität
immer verbindet dass das so eine
ursächliche kite also eine fast schon
eine wirklichkeit mit dem spiel seiner
art von kraft und das kann natürlich
jetzt jugend hier nicht mehr mit zeigen
die kraft die welt völlig raus und auch
die regular ried selbst ist steht auf
tönernen füßen weil wir regula ried
natürlich nie für alle zukünftigen fälle
apriori also unabhängig von erfahrung
begründen können die regular ried
verdankt sich einem induktion schluss
auf basis von endlichen erfahrung dieser
abfolge anschluss auf zukünftige fälle
also es steht alles ein bisschen ist
alles sehr prekär und immanuel kant den
wir in der nächsten sitzung behandelt
werden er versucht jetzt ebenso zeigen
dass die kausalität relation apriori
denkbar ist also das leben kausalität
sehr wohl behandelt behauptet werden
darf in der welt und das dieses kausale
schließen dass dieser schluss also diese
zutat die wir in diese ereignis abfolge
hineinlegen dass dieses hineinlegen
selbst nichts bloß empirisch disponiert
es ist so dass dieses hinein legen der
kausalen verbindung vielmehr ein durch
und durch rationale aktes also darin
unterscheiden sie sagen es kommt vom
subjekt diese notwendige beziehung nur
sagt kant insofern ist vom subjekt kommt
ist es gerade objektiv und hier um sagt
insofern ist vom subjekt kommt ist es
gerade nicht objektiv das ist gerade
relativ
also man kann das jetzt mit allen
begriffen hier das ist normal guter
hinweis zum schluss mit all diesen
begriffen die wir aufgeschrieben habe
mit ich raumzeit kausalität die
verhalten sich bei jungen bei kant genau
gleich also während jungs sagt wir
können für mich kein sinneseindruck
haben
das ist bloß eine empirische
konstruktion des dicht sagt kant genauso
wie bei der qualität es gehört zu
unserer nationalität genauso raum und
zeit während jung das sind frage
gestellt haben uns zeit als gegenstände
wir haben davon keinen eindruck sind die
bedingung der möglichkeit und ich um das
ins empirische wieder nimmt sagt kant
nein raum und zeit gehören zu unserer
rationalen ausstattung sind reine
anschauungs form der rhein sinnlichkeit
ja
genau ja genau also während jung sagt
raum und zeit sind keine gegenstände
erkenntnis also existieren sie
tendenziell so jetzt nicht objektiv sagt
kant daraus dass raum und zeit keine
gegenstände der erkenntnis sind folgen
nicht dass sie nicht irgendwie doch
wirklich sein können sondern sie sind
wirklich auf einer anderen ebene sind
die bedingungen die möglichkeiten sind
die rahmenbedingungen innerhalb deren
erkenntnis auftreten kann genauso ist
auch mit dem ich auch dass ich es nach
kant eine rahmenbedingung damit
überhaupt kenntnis auftreten kann und
dessen intendant transzendentale mit
transzendentalen meinte die bedingung
der möglichkeit von erfahrungen und jung
schließt eben diese möglichkeit aus
jetzt haben wir also einen schönen
hintergrund und sehen uns dann in einer
woche wieder